let me pull up the story we got from uh
from fox news
cnn's jim acosta compares virginia to
soviet-style police state under glenn
younkin
critics took to social media to blast a
cost as comparison calling it a bridge
too far and evil well as you as you all
uh may not be aware jim acosta is doing
some show on cnn called democracy in
peril i think it's funny that glenn
younkin only just got into office
there's no soviet-style police of
anything nothing's barely anything's
happening meanwhile in dc you need to
show your papers to get into a
restaurant yeah exactly but not but not
to vote
not to vote so the question what what
exactly does it cost to think the
parallel is here he's lying yeah you
know and and i don't know if he's in new
york or atlanta or dc but
in our nation's capital
if you want to visit the capitol and
protest it's more difficult to do so
especially if you're not vaccinated if
you want to communicate with your
elected representatives it's nearly
impossible to do so we have that rump
committee
threatening and talking about throwing
out hundreds of members of congress
because they opposed
the
they were involved in the election
disputes you have the justice department
talking about investigating thousands of
people because they were opposed to the
election disputes that's the
soviet-style approach to governance you
see joe walsh good for you on twitter
no i know i know who he is i didn't see
it he said anybody who tries to put
forth a fake group of electors should be
investigated or blah blah blah so so let
me just which democrats did in 1960
why that's right so what they made up a
fake story rachel maddow talks about it
she's like i've discovered
forgery documents they're shut up
they're not forgeries what happened was
when the election was being contested
whatever your opinion is is not the
point
republicans said we are going to fill
out the forms the same as the democrats
were and we're going to submit them and
sure enough when the official electors
came in and were certified for the
democrats they went and pence chose them
and it was 1960 i believe right yeah
nixon versus kennedy hawaii certified
republican electors but the democrats
decided to go and and fill out their own
forms anyway
lo and behold the courts ruled in their
favor so when the uncertified democrat
electors went to to the joint session of
congress nixon said we know what
happened the courts have ruled so i'm
gonna pick these anyway
imagine that it's historical precedent
but now you've got these lot these
people lying about it and that's what i
say this is why i say the the culture
war is between people who know and
people who don't know because if you've
read i read about that stuff in 1960
years ago with with nixon i was reading
it years ago and you know with the
midterm elections or whatever and so
when all this stuff comes up i'm like oh
yeah they just did what happened in 1960
but you know media lies about it yeah
yeah i mean in my view there's a special
place in hell for politicians
uh who want to
put their political opponents in jail i
mean to me that is a particularly grave
evil should be a donald trump jail for
him donald trump said hillary clinton
should be in jail well i don't think
he's he said she should be he should be
processed she should be prosecuted and
she did he didn't want to put her in
jail because she didn't he didn't like
her politics he thought he commit she
committed crimes here you have the
leftist saying
oh participating under the first
amendment and a rally is an evidence of
a crime participating under the
constitutional system to challenge
electors and federal law to challenge
electors that we've done since time
immemorial that all of a sudden is a
crime right it's it's more pernicious
than that it's one thing to say i think
this person committed a crime
she stole all her emails i mean we were
involved in that it's another thing to
say i don't like your politics and you
should be censored and you're a criminal
and a terrorist that's what they're
saying
in a casual way
yeah also i want to mention this i mean
the um the the clinton campaign wanted
to have u.s intelligence officials brief
the electoral college on russian
interference in order to sway them so
they i mean they have absolutely no
respect for the system or ensuring that
the electorate or those in the electoral
college select those who were voted for
we went through
five years yeah technically now it's
seven years but i was you know before uh
in 2020 had been five years of lies
about russia and ukraine and all of that
manipulation you want to talk hey jim
jim
you want to talk about soviet-style
police state let's talk about how some
dude who works for the cia accuses the
president of some nonsense and the
people of this country can't even say
his name please don't say his name
because we can't because uh you want to
know who's who's enforcing the
soviet-style police state it is uh the
democratic establishment it is the media
is social media if we say the name of
this guy youtube will take the stream
down well and that's exactly the thing
so i think the best way to summarize a
soviet-style system and the perils in
america are as follows in 2016 it was
alleged that the election was fraudulent
and in that instance we investigated
those who were elected
in 2020 it was also alleged that the
election was fraudulent this time we
investigated the people making the
accusation yeah othello isn't doing this
since
68 they thought nixon stole the election
they had secret negotiations with
vietnam
72 he overwhelmingly won
so the left used watergate to relitigate
he cheated his way in 1980 reagan had
secret talks with iran his his election
was invalid
i saw this i think snopes tried doing a
fact check on it but it said something
like every election since 1968 the
democrats have claimed has been stolen
is that well i it's at seven two
thousand i was down counting dallas in
2000 wow gore was running around trying
to change the results
and then uh 2000 uh well then now we're
in 2016
with the uh with trump
they tried to change they tried to
change the results i'm just
i'm just tired of it i got to be honest
i'm tired of it with the trump
supporters to be honest i'm tired of it
i've been tired of it from before this
it's just
look i i just want to get to the point
where
we move forward
but i think we need to understand at
this point
2020
2068 whatever year i don't care
nobody's playing by the rules anymore
and i mean that figuratively and
somewhat literally what i mean is it's
like you know walsh on twitter being
like we should lock up the people forged
these documents but they didn't that's a
lie
when they subpoena alex jones
these subpoenas from the january sex
committee we had i think i think bannon
may have told us this expensive
you can't just get subpoenaed and be
like okay tell me where to go yeah yeah
yeah there's cash they said it's fifteen
thousand dollars to look at it to just
to look at yeah yep and so what they're
doing is they're draining resources
they're using the power of the federal
government to to uh suppress
to shut down
dissonance the weight of the government
is going after political rivals in a way
donald trump never did the man talked
big and said to hillary oh you'd be in
jail and then did nothing yeah yeah he
did nothing did you see the politico
story the other day that confirmed or
showed that the capitol hill police
department which answers now to pelosi
and schumer pelosi is the queen of the
hill when it comes to security is
gathering intelligence on members
under the guise of security
investigating where they're going who
they're meeting with donors and staff
so you've got this unholy melding of a
police force with a political party i
bet that they're thinking if we don't
observe and spy on everyone the chinese
ccp is going to do it so we have to take
we have to be the ultimate spy network i
think that's the mentality well many of
them are on the payroll
oh yeah so it's bigger than the
governments and it's more of a
multinational coercive yeah i would get
down with that i do think we're winning
you know the the like the raid on
on james o'keefe it just shows you how
completely desperate the establishment
is to maintain their their their power
now that was a wild abuse of power and
uh we just got documents last week i
don't know if you saw that's right the
pfizer stuff i mean we was james talking
about was he on with you recently
talking about it yeah he was on but i
don't think he i don't think we talked
about it so we was like right afterwards
this was fun because sometimes when they
tell you no you learn something so we
asked the fbi give us records about
communications with pfizer about project
veritas
and they said we can't give you those
because they're in an investigative file
oh confirming their existence normally
they don't confirm it so it was kind of
an odd response yeah so they've
confirmed that pfizer is with working
with the fbi somehow to target project
veritas
who had for those who don't know had
done some expose on
stem cells fetal cells and being
involved or fetal organs being involved
in the
creation and
helping guarantee the safety of vaccines
things that they didn't want out there
which are true
but they don't like it out there because
people get upset about it but that's
just the veritas thing is a really good
example of the desperation
to be to be that overt with your
strategies to go against american
journalists it just shows to use the
metaphor we've used non-stop for the
past two weeks the emperor has no
clothes
but they had they had power for a long
time and it's it's being ripped from
them i think the internet is is what's
causing it yeah well it's just at this
point imagine trusting a journalist who
the entire system isn't trying to crush
yeah when uh
any news channel that puts on adam
schiff i'm just immediately like okay
it's fake news yeah exactly off exactly
nancy pelosi too lap dogs i mean i think
it's fair to bring those people on if
you're if you're adversarial but if you
want to make fun of them you know
i don't know i
i'm all big part of like ban the account
not the person i don't think that just
because someone has a track record of
lying that they're necessarily lying so
i don't want to discount these people
flat out i understand that there's maybe
it's more of a variance scale and maybe
someone that lies a lot is like maybe a
seven percent weight to their statement
but that's still seven percent
i don't know man so you're right that it
is technically possible for somebody to
lie about something and then tell the
truth later on but a person loses their
credibility and honestly there are so
many people trying to compete for our
bandwidth that i have no interest in
giving my attention to someone who i
know has lied before you know with
politics uh you don't repeatedly i don't
really care whether someone lies too
much in politics i mean it's a problem
you know morally it's objectionable as a
voter it's the corruption that bothers
me
adam schiff
abused his power to take the phone
records of rudy giuliani and publish
them
and then we go to court trying to get
the records and part of their argument
was we can do that and we don't need a
court authorization authorization to do
it so right now we know that they're
taking the phone records of people and
who knows internet records and
potentially i don't know millions of
people the way they're awarding these
requests
and there's no control or public
policing of it yeah you know that's an
abuse of power that's corrupt it's not
even they're even using subpoenas
anymore they're just requesting the
information so if you're if you were a
supporter of trump online and made
comments on election and you had your
account deleted or censored that's the
sort of stuff that congress is asking
for information on i mean do you want
that in the hands of congress or adam
schiff these are like i keep on saying
these are our republic is under assaults
and and this isn't political differences
this is a question of whether or not
we're going to follow the law and we're
going to follow the cons the
infrastructure the constitution is laid
out for us and how we govern ourselves
or whether the bad guys are just going
to break all the rules to go after their
enemies they change the law the patriot
acts insane but they made that legal so
that now they can legally just take all
the records legally even though it's
still corrupt well yeah i mean the fbi
hasn't backed off from their targeting
of parents as terrorists i mean there
was controversy about it but they're
still doing it yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm now don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you